you look good you look fantastic I don't
think I've ever really see you dressed
up this nicely smooth nice move yeah
you look you look fantastic you've got a
little bit of a Trebek thing going why
thank you with the suit and the stache
is that your final no what does he say
what is a a compliment thank you look at
that look at those eyes you've got the
best peepers in the business look at
that face look at that guy come on you
gotta love that guy how are you I'm very
well thank you you have a new show full
bush that's right that you're taking out
across screen now tell us let's just get
it out on the table
what is full bush what is it what are
you intending to mean by the title full
bush I'm glad you asked Conan there are
a few entendre x' to the title of my
show
one is involves you know barreling into
a situation headfirst without properly
advising oneself of all the information
one needs much like our recent president
george w bush going full bush means
diving in yeah
guiding have okay diving in without
proper education
I'm not another iteration of the title
is living living one's life in a way you
know at some point all these great
technological systems that make our
lives happy they're all made by humans
which means they're going to crash at
some point and we're going to be left
without our gadgets and so I always keep
at least three knives on me and I'm I'm
always aware of if things go down at any
given time where there's meat there's a
lot of meat out there yeah but you know
that game when you're on a subway train
and you're like okay who who would we
eat first
yeah and who would know I don't play
that on a subway
who's gonna procreate yeah on this train
that's living that's that's living full
bush it's living full bush you know I
would ready to go out into the bush and
then of course the third ways is wearing
a proud bristling shining pubic thicket
as mother nature intended right I mean I
know you guys are on board with that
well we live in an era where a lot of
men now manscape an abomination of
english-language term you again you're
against the whole concept of manscaping
if people yeah I mean the whole lower
the pudenda region was that's Mother
Nature's billboard you know it mother
nature's billboard yeah not it should it
should say you know ready to
you
not only not only should you not be
trimming and shaving you should maintain
a swampy atmosphere that's just just shy
of growing fungus you want that to be a
swampy primordial sea down there should
be giving off a hot musk that you can
almost taste
[Laughter]
is this how you really feel you think
that all men should do this and the
women absolutely men and women this is
how you like to roll if you if you I
hope you never are see the horrific
sight of a beaver shaved in the wild you
know swimming and swimming in a lake but
they are not meant to go without hair
okay I think the police are here demesne
agree for agree
the police are here to end your segment
we're gonna come back and do another
segment after we talk to your lawyers
more with Nick Offerman after this
you